a powerful earthquake has struck
northeastern japan injuring more than
130 people
and leaving some 860 000 homes without
power
experts believe the quake was an
aftershock from the massive
tremor that hit the region 10 years ago
woken up with a jolt a strong
overnight quake as it hit northeastern
japan off the coast of fukushima
the initial quake was followed by a
series of aftershocks
it was like an explosion it shook so
much that all of our tableware fell
we haven't had a large earthquake in a
while and this one was really big
it made me remember the past
back in 2011 a similar earthquake in the
same region triggered a tsunami
that caused a severe nuclear accident
the fukushima nuclear power plant had a
meltdown that leaked radiation into the
atmosphere
and the pacific ocean the cleanup from
that disaster will likely take another
30 to 40 years
the japanese prime minister has
dismissed worries that fukushima's
nuclear plant could suffer a new leak
from this latest quake
as residents began cleaning up the
aftermath
officials are calling on people to
remain on the alert
for further aftershocks in the coming
weeks